[Musik]
seit elf wochen bestimmt der krieg in
der ukraine unsere nachrichten und
schlagzeilen und es zeigt sich wie sehr
bilder diesen krieg prägen in diesem
fall besonders die darstellung der
mächtigen putin gegen sie lenski zwei
männer die sich seit beginn des krieges
ganz unterschiedlich präsentieren der
ukrainische präsident zeigt sich seinem
volk im olivgrünen t shirt fast täglich
den russischen staatschef den sieht
jeder sofort an seinem langen tisch
sitzen die botschaft der bilder
inszenierung im krieg darüber reden wir
in dieser phoenix runde
[Musik]
phoenix runde
guten abend herzlich willkommen aus
berlin ich darf ihnen meine gäste
vorstellen bei uns ist thore schröder er
ist krisen reporter für den spiegel
berichtet seit einigen wochen aus der
ukraine und war zuvor freier reporter
unter anderem aus afghanistan und dem
nahen osten und jetzt gerade auf
heimaturlaub
thema parken ist bei uns chefredakteurin
von ost west europäische perspektiven
und auch mitbegründerin und
vorstandsmitglied der deutschen sektion
von reporter ohne grenzen
zugeschaltet ist sonst johannes hillje
er ist selbstständiger politik und
kommunikationsberater zu seinen kunden
gehören ministerien und parteien und
2014 hat er bei der europawahl den
wahlkampf der grünen gemanagt und
herzlich willkommen nur dass kirchner er
ist politikwissenschaftler und
psychologe und trainer für kommunikation
und bevor wir hier miteinander darüber
reden ja wie die bilder wirken schauen
wir uns mal zwei kurze ausschnitte an
über die beiden präsidenten von dieser
woche vom 9 wir beginnen mit vladimir
selensky
am 24 august 2021 hat die ganze ukraine
den dreißigsten jahrestag der
unabhängigkeit des landes gefeiert auf
der hauptstraße marschierten unsere
streitkräfte das war eben vor einem jahr
darin erinnert seelands g mit diesem
videoclip wo er alleine auf der
hauptstraße marschiert und in russland
sah das alles anders aus am 9 mai
präsentierte sich putin
ich wende mich an unsere streitkräfte
und an unsere streitkräfte vom don was
ihr kämpft für das vaterland und dort
marschierten wie immer am 9 mai auf dem
roten platz dann die soldaten und
präsentierte sich das militär
also zwei unterschiedliche zwei
machthaber in ganz unterschiedlichen
positionen proporz kann wenn sie das so
sehen die beiden männer die ja sozusagen
so wichtig sind für diesen krieg als
auch als figuren an denen man sich
festhält welche botschaften werden da
gesetzt also der gegensatz könnte ja
nicht größer seien nicht auf der einen
seite haben wir wladimir putin den wir
sonst vor allem mit diesem langen tisch
in verbindung bringen aber jetzt eben
mit veteranen im hintergrund bei der
militär parade das vermittelt natürlich
den eindruck sozusagen einer einer
völlig überkommenen alten welt
wohingegen sie lenski natürlich als
medienunternehmer und schauspieler eine
wirklich moderne kommunikation
eigentlich kriegsbeginn und schon davor
irgendwie aufweisen konnte und ich finde
das macht er sehr beeindruckend nicht
also erreicht ich glaube ich sehr viele
menschen in seinem eigenen land und
schaffte es so zu sagen so ein
gemeinschaftsgefühl zu stärken also ich
höre auch von vielen ukrainern dass sie
sich darin bestärkt und auch durchaus
eben
ermutigt fühlen durch diesen präsidenten
der ja wirklich täglich auftaucht der
eben auch nicht nur im eigenen land
sondern finde ich weit über die grenzen
hinaus
präsent und in einer positiven weise
glaube ich überwiegend weil er eben
direkt spricht zu den menschen ich fand
besonders eindrucksvoll eigentlich ganz
am anfang seine rede auch an das
russische volk die hat es ja auch
gegeben das vergisst man manchmal dass
er sich eben in alle richtungen
eigentlich kommunikativ gewendet hat
dann eben auch in rohstoff in die
russische sprache aber fragen wir mal
direkt nach eher spröder sie waren jetzt
lange in der ukraine unterwegs wie wir
haben ja ein ganz positives bild von
selen alle sagen wer macht das so toll
ist das kommt es genau so an in der
ukraine sind alle so positiv von ihm ja
ich hab keine
demoskopischen untersuchung gemacht aber
mit vielen leuten gesprochen haben in
verschiedenen landesteilen auch wir sind
relativ viel unterwegs gewesen vor allem
online kiew und dann im umland von kiew
auch inszeniert bis hoch und dann im
labor und im donbass und es geht ein
bisschen auseinander das gros der leute
die sind wirklich froh darüber bis hin
zu den hipstern von kiew die sagen
eigentlich sie denn die politik
insgesamt war uns nichts vor das hat uns
nicht interessiert so dann ging der
krieg los und so das ist jetzt unser
präsident die 10-jährige rechte fans
geworden die ersten tage waren dawanda
prägen von dawanda maßgebend
dahingehend dahingegen im don was ich
glaube da sind einfach ein paar ich
möchte sie nicht unverbesserlichen aber
leute die einfach
ja parteigänger russlands sind und die
der von der russischen armee noch
beschlossen werden und dann sagen ja wie
kann das denn angehen wir sind doch
eigentlich an diese wensky er lernte ich
von anfang an eben präsentiert auch in
diesem olivgrünen shirt auch ganz am
anfang wird nach kriegsbeginn sah man
ihn mit beratern hat er als held wie
gemacht das zeigen wir wie sehen wir
bestimmt auch gleich noch mal die frage
dieses das was der lenski da präsentiert
als jemand der zu dem volk gehört und
der de das ja anscheinend sehr
erfolgreich macht was ist das was ist
das positive daran wie oder bibel
bewerten sie das was er da macht es
gerade schon den zentralen punkt
angesprochen es schafft ein ungeheures
gemeinschaftsgefühl und
zusammengehörigkeitsgefühl in der
ukrainischen bevölkerung und eine
ebenbürtigkeit und das ist ja auch der
zentrale unterschied zu putin und auch
der zentrale unterschied im herrschafts
verständnis dieser beiden
politiker der drückt sich in der
kommunikation auch putin will als
autokratischer alleinherrscher nicht neu
aber wirken apple eine hierarchische
distanz ja geradezu eine angst machen
der distanz auch zu seinem volks waren
und sie lenski dagegen die bürgernähe
und zusammenhalt schaffen und dadurch
auch die menschen motivieren
überhaupt die hoffnung zu behalten sich
aber auch zum teil am krieg zu
beteiligen das war ja auch am anfang des
krieges mit der aufruf da haben wir
anleitung gesehen grunde für jeden
ukrainischen bürger für die bürgerinnen
molotow cocktails zu bauen und ich
glaube was er wirklich geschafft hat ist
diese botschaft zu vermitteln ich kämpfe
mit euro verteidigen uns zusammen das
hält was sie gerade gezeigt haben da ist
er in militärkleidung mit seinen
kabinettskollegen
und das ist ja wirklich das stärkste
symbol wenn er auf der straße steht mit
seinen kameraden und ist dann
gleichzeitig aber auch die größte
distanz zu putin in seinem palast oder
eben im rednerpult wie jetzt am neunten
mal der wirklich überhaupt keine form
der ebenbürtigkeit und nahbar kite und
natürlich auch keine teilnahme an
irgendeine form des kampfes
demonstriert das ist wirklich glaube ich
der fundamentale unterschied in der
inszenierung der beiden kirchen kann man
ja sagen das sind zwei männer die sich
versuchen eben diese stärke zeigen
wollen entschlossenheit zeigen wollen
und dafür jeweils andere symbole wählen
also auch dieser dieser lange tisch von
putin ist ja auch etwas zu sagen hier
ich bin derjenige der hier so ein diesen
langen tisch hat und der dann dadurch
wirken dann meine
gesprächspartner weit weg also ist es
funktioniert funktioniert das zeigen
sich beide letztendlich stark
sie zeigen sich beide stark aber sie
zeigen sich weiter auf eine sehr
unterschiedliche art stark wenn wir ganz
kurz die sbb dem was sie gerade gezeigt
haben diesen langen tisch dann war es ja
an der stelle so dass putin sehr weit
vorne saß und der gesprächspartner seit
hinten und auch sehr klein war das heißt
es war nicht nur die distanz des tisches
sondern es war vor allem dieses wer
steht hier an dieser stelle vorne aber
ich würde alles was er hier gesagt hat
aber ich denke man kann sie lenski
kommunikation 2 in wort und bild am
besten mit der theorie der person nach
cellini erklären er hat gesagt werden so
7 überzeugungs prinzipien wir können es
schaffen durch gegenseitigkeit denn sein
bild ist immer ich bin bei euch und ich
opfer mich auch auf er hat ja das
angebot der amerikaner abgelehnt sich
evakuieren zu lassen er schafft es über
sympathie indem er zeigt wir sind
diejenigen die hier überfallen wurden er
schafft es über autorität weil er sagt
das was hier passiert diese bilder von
butscher von rp das ist etwas was
überhaupt gar nicht geht er schafft es
über verknappung indem er sagt die zeit
rast ihr müsst uns jetzt helfen er
schafft es über commitment indem er sagt
ihr sollt jetzt eben das tun was ihr
immer gesagt dass europäer nämlich eure
werte verteidigen und so etwas hier
nicht wieder zu lassen und das hat er
gesagt über die entsprechende
zusammengehörigkeit als die amerikaner
eben das angeboten haben dann hat er ja
nicht nur die bilder gezeigt wurde
mitten unter den leuten war man hat
gesagt ich brauche kein taxi ich brauche
munition und genau dieses gefühl von
zusammengehörigkeit von loyalität und
das ist ein solcher gesellschaft auch
welche im zweifel von persönlicher
opferbereitschaft das hat ihn eben ein
großes maß an glaubwürdigkeit gegeben
und er setzt damit natürlich auch den
besten unter druck frogs kann ist das
redlich eigentlich mit dieser art
sozusagen auch einen druck aufzubauen ja
ich hatte gerade nachdem wir uns alle so
positiv geäußert haben aus der sich zu
sagen der kommunikation wird auch
gedacht dass ich so in meinem herzen
natürlich vor allem journalistin bin und
es da natürlich mit vielen problemen
verbunden ist diese art der
kommunikation die ja in vielen ländern
zunimmt nicht dass sozusagen politiker
zunehmend einen weg suchen direkt zu
kommunizieren über diese kanäle und uns
manchmal sozusagen beiseite lassen also
es gab jetzt eine pressekonferenz eine
wirklich wichtige vom see lenski in der
u-bahn irgendwie mitten in kiew wo viele
pressevertreter da waren aber sonst gibt
es schon auch eine leise kritik an eben
dass er eben medienanfragen nicht immer
beantwortet dass er sozusagen schwer
über diese üblichen kanäle irgendwie
erreichbar ist und insofern liegt für
uns als journalisten auch eine gewisse
gefahr in dieser sehr modernen
kommunikation weil wir ihm sehen müssen
wir wohl wäre da unsere rolle finden und
eben auch aufpassen müssen dass man
nicht
mächtigen menschen auf den leim geht
weil sie eben so toll kommunizieren
können okay wer schröder bei ihr ist da
ihre erfahrung sie haben ja jetzt in der
ukraine berichtet sie waren in butter
gibt es punkte wo sie das gefühl haben
sie ja da wird man gesteuert oder können
sie ganz frei berichten jetzt weg von
der figur selensky ganz frei berichten
nicht aber steuerung ist es auch nicht
halt gerade das beispiel butscher da
wollten wir natürlich hin es war bevor
das dann vor aller augen klar wurde was
da passiert ist und die gleichen
wirklich auf allen kanälen und in allen
zeitschriften auf allen websites waren
fast tagelang kaum möglich dahin zu
gelangen das kam schon so einzelne
bilder videos clips die fundierten so
raus über twitter von den soldaten die
davert oder anderen helfen einzelne
kollegen die auch schon da waren wir
wollten halt unbedingt dahin und das
militär hat aber zugemacht so was ja
dagegen spricht dass das eine
inszenierung war
und zwar wahrscheinlich aus dem grund
dass sie nicht noch mal es zulassen
wollten dass journalisten wirklich zu
schaden kommen weil die gefahr war
gegeben da waren wegen ihnen wegen
blindgängern wegen auch einfach jahr
wegen wegen wegen sprengfallen wir haben
das selber gesehen den erp wir sind dann
einen packen darf nicht im park gegangen
da lag die leiche eines mannes da war
eine klasse klavier seite ran und am
ende dieser klavier seite war im prinzip
so eine coole da war eine
handgranate wahrscheinlich zur explosion
gebracht worden würde ich mal sagen also
das wurde schon entschärft an der stelle
und es war an dem tag auch die rede
davon dass die russen das immer wieder
machen in diesen gebieten wo sie
abgezogen sind und wir sind dann weil
wir irgendwie ein bisschen trickreich
sind wir dann nach bahrain gekommen weil
wir in münchen bleiben konnten dann
mussten wir nicht zurück nach dem fund
waren daneben schon da und konnten dann
am nächsten morgen eben von erb in das
ist ja dann ein orten ist sozusagen die
nächste vorstand von kiew ein ort weiter
nach bahrain und das wollen wir da rein
und ja als erste bild das so einer weide
nahe war der erste war stand dann ein
ford kombi auf der seite stand eben die
kinder der offenbar beschlossen wurde
wurde auf jeden fall dazu zum stoppen
gebracht und dann ging es los mit mit
wachs von familie fahrzeugen und so
weiter und dann fuhren wir nicht statt
rein unterlagen die gleichen einfach
unter anderem ein mann in einem nieder
gewalzten auto da waren die wahl offen
sich der russische panzer noch drüber
gefahren und dann gucken diese leiche
lag da seit vier wochen drin und den
hatten sie hinten durch den kopf
geschossen oder durch den hals und dann
sagten die und da sind auch noch leichen
und da sind auch noch leichen zivilisten
wohl bemerkt und es war soviel es war so
vielstimmig und es waren so viele
leichen
dass das und das ging dann an anderen
orten auch weiter dass das keine
inszenierung gewesen sein kann es gab ja
dann den vorwurf von russischer seite
das ist eine inszenierung gewesen
natürlich gibt es dass ich meine es gibt
es immer das ist ja nur ein trick 17 das
würde man geführt
es hat sich ja vieles dann konzentriert
auf diese jablonska straße da hier sind
dann erst auf die straße das ist die
roxeler straße da wo die russen zuerst
russische mir zuerst angekommen waren 2
ich glaube 25 februar wird
luftlandetruppen ausrüstung und dann mit
ich glaube artillerie zerstört wurde im
prinzip und dann sind sie raus und dann
sind sie noch mal wieder rein und das
war ich auch schon der grund warum die
russische armee so auf zinne war als sie
einfach nach nach bahrain dann war klar
mit durch diese bilder in butter nimmt
das alles noch mal eine andere wendung
und dann nochmal ein oder sagen wir mal
so es wurde diese bilder waren ja noch
mal sehr prägend dass ich nicht ob es da
andere wendung jetzt für die russen
genommen hat ich meine wenn man immer
alles abstreitet dann muss man sich auch
nicht dafür rechtfertigen da muss man
auch nicht darauf reagieren für die
ukraine wir reden jetzt darüber welche
bilder diesen krieg prägen und wie man
damit umgeht naja ich meine das war ende
märz richtig das war glaube ich reichste
31 sind die raus ausputzer jetzt haben
wir anfangen noch anfang mai richtig und
wir haben diese diskussion in
deutschland von wo man denkt offenbar
haben sie nicht die richtige wirkung ab
diese bilder
haley was würden sie sagen sie haben wir
darüber gesprochen wie sich die dichte
lenski und putin darstellen und dann so
etwas wie ein geschehen in butter was
wiederum auch von russischer seite dann
angegriffen wurde gesagt das ist eine
inszenierung
welche bilder sind dann letztendlich
dann doch mächtiger
das mächtigste bild ist wahrscheinlich
dass eines ermordeten und toten menschen
und dann die leichen von kindern die wir
auch ausrutscher gesehen haben also wir
haben ja gehe ich jetzt mal davon aus
konsens in dieser runde kein zweifel
daran dass das keine inszenierung war
und russland sozusagen im zuge ihrer
permanenten des informationsstrategie
natürlich wie er schröder sagt alles
abstreitet und da muss man im grunde
glaube ich gar nicht weiter darauf
eingehen wie russland auch sowas aber
wirken aber was ist das trotzdem wirkt
das in dem moment wo man sagt dass also
indem man das in dem russland sagt das
könnte inszeniert sein also hat
entfaltet das doch eine wirkung
ich habe leider das gefühl das ist eine
viel zu große wirkung entfaltet also sie
mag sozusagen nicht durchschlagen gerade
in unserer öffentlichkeit aber ich
wundere mich schon manchmal darum
darüber wie auch immer wieder diese
russischen statements bei uns dann in
den überschriften dann in bestimmten
artikeln also ich habe gerade nach
dieser aussage aus der russischen
regierung zu dieser also vermeintlichen
inszenierung dann über schriften gelesen
wie russland wirft ukraine
inszenierungen butscher vor punkt das
waren überschriften den deutschen medien
liefen und da frage ich mich manchmal
also sind journalisten haben die die
aufgabe des informationen zu verbreiten
ihre leser zu des informieren oder haben
sie die aufgabe zu informieren nicht
würde mir manchmal irgendwie ein
bisschen mehr ja sozusagen
selbstbewusstsein mit diesem umgang auch
wünschen von russischer desinformationen
es gibt einfach
kein zweifel an diesen geschehnissen und
wir haben ja genug
berichterstatter wir haben einfach uns
hier in der runde der vor ort ist
deswegen ist das glaube ich überhaupt
auch keine frage von glaubwürdige
quellen oder so und ich glaube man darf
man oder man sollte diese russischen
bams -informationen weniger warum geben
weil wir merken ja dass auch in
deutschland immer noch leute
russische propaganda verfallen wir haben
eine partei im bundestag die
ängste verknüpfung immer noch zu
russland pflegt die auch russland nicht
die schuld wirklich zuweisen will an
diesem krieg die immer eine rhetorik der
beidseitig kai pflegt und wir haben auch
immer noch demonstration pro-russische
demonstration auf unseren straßen also
ich glaube man kann sich da auch als
öffentlichkeit etwas selbstbewusstsein
gegen diese desinformationskampagne
aufstellen herr kirchner was ist ihrer
meinung nach da der gute umgang damit
naja vielleicht guckt man es erstmal
noch mal an warum das ganze funktioniert
denn wir hatten ja eine situation dass
wirklich ganz viele so der meinung von
russland wird das nicht machen ja das
können wir uns nicht vorstellen die
ganze sache aber es gab ja auch leute
russland verteidigt haben und jetzt ist
die situation die haben russland
verteidigt russland führt jetzt diesen
angriffskrieg und das erzeugt bei uns
selber ja erstmal der kognitive
dissonanz das heißt wir müssen uns damit
auseinandersetzen jemand verteilt zu
haben wir jetzt diese verbrechen begeht
in dem moment wo man aktiv unten wird
was sagt das tun die gar nicht das war
doch nur eine inszenierung ist für mich
selber die kognitive dissonanz deutlich
geringer das ist der erste effekt
erwirkt der zweite effekt wirkt ist und
das kann man mit dem modell der
informationsverarbeitung erklären wer am
ersten bauchgefühl und dann haben wir es
später die rationalisierung und wenn
mein bauchgefühl ist die russen können
das nicht gewesen sein oder die sind
nicht so schlimm dann werde ich jede
information die mir hilft mein
bauchgefühl zu bestätigen entsprechend
hoch gewichten und deswegen macht
russland natürlich das angebot es zielt
auf diejenigen die sie nicht komplett
verlieren wollen und diejenigen die und
das sehen wir jetzt ein sogenanntes
generalisierte institutionen misstrauen
haben das heißt ihr vertrauen nicht
wirklich der regierung sie vertrauen
nicht wirklich den medien für die es
natürlich jetzt diese situation dass man
sagt ob das hier alles stimmt auch ob
das was wir jetzt hier gerade aus dieser
phoenix runde sagen ob das überhaupt
stimmt die nehmen sich dann eben als
gegenbeispiel das russische weil das ist
die antithese zum mainstream und so kann
man sich auch erklären warum ein teil
eben genau bei einem teil der leute
genau diese dessen fans und verfängt er
möchte allerdings an der stadt kurz denn
hier widersprechen ich finde es richtig
dass da steht russland wirft vor aber
dann sollte man titel deutlich werden
wie plausibel bezüglich unplausibel
dieser vorwurf ist
deswegen
glaube ich kann man da schon ein stück
weiter gehen wir haben die erfahrung ja
auch mit donald trump gemacht er hat
genau diesen effekt ja auch immer wieder
oder diesen wirkmechanismus der medien
genutzt dass seine zitate überschriften
geladen sind gelandet sind und dann
nichts weiter stand und wir haben einen
lernkurve bei us amerikanischen medien
gesehen die dann irgendwann nicht mehr
einfach seine lügen behafteten zitat den
überschriften gesetzt haben sondern zb
am wahltag die wahl die er verloren hat
hieß dann eine überschrift in der new
york times oder auf der webseite der new
york times
entgegen der fakten behaupten aber die
wahl gewonnen
ich finde das einen souveränen umgang
mit solchen lügen mit solchen wirklicher
strategisch und als zur strategie
gemachten eingesetzten lügen eines
politikers aber wir haben in deutschland
eine ganz andere situation aus meiner
sicht also diese gruppen über diese
sprechen sind ja ganz klar in der
minderheit und da wir hier über bilder
sprechen glaube ich es ist eben auch ein
krieg der sehr stark wie viele kriege
aber ich glaube in besonderer weise ein
krieg der bilder ist nicht also weil ich
kann mich nicht erinnern dass so viele
eindrucksvolle bilder die menschen auf
so direkten wege erreicht haben über
social media und ich glaube es macht
eben doch für viele hier in deutschland
einen unterschied dass eben kiew so
aussieht wie eine deutsche stadt und man
eben nicht das gefühl das ist irgendwie
weit weg sondern das ist sehr nahe und
wenn man mit menschen spricht hat man
also in mein eindruck ist dass das eine
also auch viele dazu bewegt eben sehr
stark auch umzudenken sich ganz anders
zu interessieren für die ukraine also wo
viele von uns russland export osteuropa
expertin und ukraine experten zu sagen
er immer hatten dass kein mensch fährt
dahin man hat komische vorstellung und
ich muss sagen wenn es irgendwie einen
kleinen positiven aspekt gibt in dieser
ganzen entwicklungen ist es dass jeder
jetzt weiß wo die ukraine liegt wie groß
sie ist
somit einfach vielen menschen begegnet
ist die hierher geflohen sind da gibt es
im großen lerneffekt unter spielen auch
bilder eine ganz ganz große rolle und
sie haben social media angesprochen da
würde ich gerne mal drauf eingehen herr
schröder sie sind auch aktiv bei
instagram zum beispiel und sie verfolgen
natürlich auch was was in sozialen
medien passiert wie wichtig ist das auch
für sie als reporter wenn sie auch ihre
redaktion was anbieten dass sie wissen
da ist auch das gute bild dabei es geht
nicht nur um die geschichte sondern
wichtig ist da sind da ist ein
aussagekräftiges bild da ist etwas dabei
wenn bei mir nicht weil wir nicht nur
einen langen langen text gutes foto foto
foto ein gutes foto
ich sehe das sowieso so ich komme von
tageszeitungen wir bei uns war immer
krone bild keine geschichte
insofern ich denke immer so ich möchte
auch mehrheit meiner protagonisten immer
gerne im porträt haben damit der leser
einfach dann wenn er den text durch geht
die leute sieht ich finde das wichtig
und die orte und irgendwie sagen wir mal
ich hatte eine geschichte da waren wir
ein genie ist also eine norden belagerte
stadt über fast einen monat
und da haben wir recherchiert eine
schlange wo die menschen zum protonen
anstand morgens und da haben die russen
eine panzergranate drauf geschossen und
ich da sind 15 menschen starben weitere
schwerstverletzte und wir sind da
hingekommen zehn tage später womöglich
vielleicht ein bisschen kürzer und es
war eine bananenkiste da noch auf der
auf der rampe diese supermarkt ist von
wunders ausgegeben wurde war voller blut
und ich habe mein fotografen gesagt
bitte kannst du das fotografieren da
sagte ich bin nicht im strato ungefähr
aber ich fand das extrem wichtig in dem
moment so das geht jetzt ein bisschen
weg von von instagram muss jeder text
muss jedes stück instagram
[Musik]
fähig sein weiß ich nicht muss nicht
unbedingt zu sein ich gebe immer alles
was ich dann veröffentlichte wenn ich in
solchen situationen auch da drauf und
ich krieg wahnsinnig viel rücklauf über
instagram im übrigen auch gute kontakte
und auch kritisch ist und so aber das
gros davon es ist es ist gut dass unsere
der die wahrnehmung von den ereignissen
hat eben doch noch mal immer stärker
eben durch bilder geprägt ist ist das
auch etwas wie sehen sie da auch das
agieren des ukrainischen präsidenten der
nutzt das ja auch sehr stark ja bestimmt
bestimmt ist das so es sind aber wir
haben ja von um die inszenierung und
sozusagen seine metamorphose also soll
es also äußerlich auch gesprochen das
erste diese erste rede die schon zur
sprache kam wo er viel ruß tisch geredet
habe das russische volk direkt
angesprochen da trug er noch anzug und
da war ja noch glatt rasiert und dann
hat man halt den bart wachsen lassen und
dann war irgendwann struppig und dann
wurde aber ein bisschen fülliger und
einem drucker halt dieses grüne grüne
hemd und und wie und irgendwann hat er
dann sein wie ich da gefunden aber ich
wurde auch immer müde aber man hat dann
auch mal geschlafen so aber das spielt
schon eine rolle weil ich meine das ist
etwas was man auch genauso parallel bei
den menschen im krieg erleben konnte man
konnte den ja ansehen wie der krieg sie
mitnimmt auch körperlich einfach und
psychisch das ist sehr schwer und auch
das trug dazu bei seiner glaubwürdigkeit
es gab diesen besuch von ihrem in butter
vierter april oder sowas da sah er
wirklich gezeichnet aus und auch
geschossen einfach und das wurde dann
gegenüber dass das ist dann auf
instagram gelandet und da wurden diese
beiden bilder gucken mal so sah er aus
noch ein paar tage vor kriegsbeginn
glattrasiert
schlips und kragen und jetzt von dem
kriegsgeschehen und sagte jetzt endlich
angefasst ja schauen wir mal ob
daraus was auf was wir daraus lernen
können herr hille wenn wir daraus lernen
können also wenn es um politische
kommunikation geht also wenn sich wenn
es das elend gibt präsentiert sich auf
eine art wo viele leute sagen dass dem
glaube ich das ist derjenige der mich
hier durch diesen krieg führt jetzt
haben wir natürlich auch jetzt haben wir
menschen im politiker die nach in die in
die ukraine reisen die präsentieren sich
dann auch also gibt es etwas wo sie
merken seit diesem krieg was sozusagen
abfärbt auf politiker in deutschland
also dieser trend zur social media lisi
rung der politischen kommunikation den
haben wir ja schon ganz lange und social
media lee sierung meint in diesem fall
auch eine größere bedeutung des bildes
weil viele der social media kanäle eben
vor allem auch ein zwang zum bild haben
instagram ganz besonders und wir haben
in unserem deutschen bundestagswahlkampf
letztes jahr aber mehr so ein bisschen
die die verpassten strategien in der
bildsprache einig erlebt also haben wir
viele negativbeispiele ich da jetzt nur
ganz kurz an armin laschet
gesehen und keinen wirklich
strategischen umgang mit einer eigenen
bildsprache
aber ich habe das gefühl dass sich das
auch in der deutschen kommunikation
ändert die bilder die gestern annalena
baerbock die außenministerin ich will
nicht sagen produziert hat aber die
entstanden sind bei ihrem besuch die
waren sehr ausdrucksstark die in den
meisten begriff den ich heute in der
kommentierung dieses besuchs gelesen
aber empathie und gerade auch die art
und weise wie vor wer backt das dann
macht dass sie ihren amtskollegen herrn
kollegium amt hat das ist ja noch mal
nicht nur sozusagen ein bild sonst auch
eine geste und auf dieser symbolischen
ebene hat dieser besuch gestern glaube
ich ganz viel geliefert ernten hat
brücken gebaut auch wieder zwischen den
beiden regierungen wir wissen alle wie
die vorgeschichte war im grunde ist die
brücke gebaut worden für eines der
mysterien und auch die ukraine besucht
weil sie die social ja weil sie ist
genau ansprechen dann würde ich nochmal
sagen ob auf eine seite noch schauen
nämlich auf dass twitter foto von
friedrich merz der ja auch in kiel war
vor annalena baerbock der hat sich ja
dann auf dem weg nach kef im schlafwagen
gemeldet bei coop und hat gesagt dass er
sich sicher fühlt und jetzt in dieses
schöne land reist darüber gab es auch da
gab es viel kritik daran frau kreuzigen
wie haben sie das empfunden ist das war
das jetzt ein positiv oder eher nicht ja
es ist eben das bemühen eben auch diesen
modernen anforderungen von politiker
kommunikation gerecht zu werden also wir
haben ja sozusagen so ein ganzes genre
jetzt dieses dieser reise nach kiew und
die werden natürlich entsprechend mit
bildern begleitet also denken wir noch
an die reise bei der steinmeier da nicht
mitreisen durfte das waren ja auch schon
drei herren irgendwie im zug wenn ich
mich richtig erinnere und insofern ist
es glaube ich richtig und legitim dass
auch herr merz das versucht und wir
wissen ja aus der vergangenheit dass die
cdu langsam war darin social media für
sich zu nutzen
und ich glaube das ist in der heutigen
zeit einfach erforderlich dass man das
in dieser weise tut weil eben gerade
auch für jüngere menschen glaube ich die
kommunikation über bilder noch wichtiger
wird als über text ja aber dann ist
sogar schon gesagt dass die direkte
kommunikation politiker ohne die
journalisten dazwischen ja das sind eben
die unterschiedlichen perspektiven also
deswegen ist die frage worüber reden
werde ich eine seite ist die
professionelle kommunikation und das
andere ist die frage wie informativ ist
das eigentlich und trägt es dazu bei
tatsächlich dinge besser zu verstehen
und da ist es natürlich so dass man sich
klar machen musste ist diese instrumente
eben auch instrumente sind die
propaganda sein können würde ich jetzt
also herr merz keineswegs unterstellen
oder auch anderen unserer politiker
nicht aber man bewegt sich natürlich auf
diesem dünnen eis wo man eben fragen
muss wie informativ ist das in wahrheit
was erfährt man da wirklich als
zuschauer irgendwie mehr in der kirche
als würden sie sagen wie hat sich das
verändert dann auch bei uns und wenn sie
dann sehen wie herzig präsentiert aber
auch bärbel bas hat auch ein foto von
sich gezeigt im zug also
ohne das geht es ja wahrscheinlich kaum
mehr was hat sich da so verändert ihre
meinung
na ja also es gibt so etwas was ich
nicht verändert hat nämlich fast und so
die grundsätzlichen quellen der
glaubwürdigkeit oder überhaupt der
überzeugungskraft und das selbst alles
schon in seinem rhetorik gesagt wir
können über logik überzeugen das heißt
über argumente wie die klassische rede
aber das ist das was wir kennen wir
können etwas pathos überzeugen das heißt
über gefühle über gefühle die ich auch
ansprechen will das ist die
hauptfunktion dieser medialisierung und
dieser bilder aber auch über die
persönliche glaubwürdigkeit
es ist ja ein unterschied ob er im
friedrich merz wirklich dahin fern es
ist ja auch mit einer gewissen gefahr
verbunden und olaf scholz eben nicht
dadurch konnte er sicher an teetisch
inszenieren er ist der macher er ist
derjenige der auch wirklich
unterstützung liefert während scholz der
zauberer ist deswegen war das natürlich
eine sehr bewusste und durchaus kluge
inszenierung und was noch hinzukommt das
dürfen wir nicht vergessen
bis zu 50 prozent unseres gehirns ist
mehr oder weniger an bildverarbeitung
beteiligt es gibt sogar an der
psychologie den satz wir menschen sind
visuelle tiere weil eben wirklich sehr
sehr stark ja die einfach der sinnes
kanal des sehens auch wirklich auch
unsere gedanken unser bewusstsein prägt
und wir haben ja erlebt so in den
sozialwissenschaften auch in den
kulturwissenschaften den sogenannten
pictorion dass man also viel stärker zum
bild und dessen botschaft gegangen ist
aber klar ist wir haben jetzt auch eine
eigendynamik dadurch dass eben
insbesondere instagram einfach ein
medium ist was das bild strukturellen
nahezu verlangt deswegen wird quasi der
blickt origin jetzt noch mal verstärkt
und deswegen müssen die leute jetzt
genau in dieser inszenierung gehen und
der kulminationspunkt bei uns ist robert
habeck der regelmäßig wirklich diese
kleinen videos produziert was am ehesten
an selen ski vom stil erinnert also von
jesse von der aufmachung her elia hat es
richtig gesehen dass sie dazu noch was
sagen wollten ja ich glaube wir müssen
hier noch mal auf die botschaft 7
bekommen und die finde ich dann doch
etwas kritisch bei friedrich merz
zumindest in diesem ersten statement was
er aus dem zug gepostet hat da hat er ja
im grunde nur über sich und seine eigene
sicherheit gesprochen
waren der ukraine angekommen und hat
sich aber wenig eigentlich mit dem
auseinandergesetzt was da im land
passiert das war meines erachtens ein
stück weit selbst zentriert und da merkt
man das dann ja solidarität bei solchen
besuchen auch schnell in
selbstinszenierung kippen kann ich würde
nicht sagen dass das für den gesamten
besuch von friedrich merz der fall war
er hat dann als er da war
eigentlich finde ich ganz vernünftig
kommuniziert und auch glaubwürdigkeit in
der solidarität ausgestrahlt aber als er
dann kurze zeit später schon wieder für
sich reklamierte dass jetzt das
telefonat zwischen herrn steinmeier und
fernseh lenski zustande kam dann hatte
das schon wieder ein etwas diese
schlagseite zur selbstdarstellung und
wir haben heute eine umfrage gesehen die
sagt also forsa-umfrage dass
friedrich merz dass vor allem 60 prozent
sagen dass zur selbstprofilierung
genutzt hätte diese reise und da muss
ich sagen da ist kommunikativ sein
ansatz nicht aufgegangen das ist ja
genau das die punkt einerseits muss man
sich personen nicht zeigen und soll sich
auch als als mensch als person zeigen
und dann ist es eben die frage um was
geht es dabei herr schröder würden sie
denn sagen
konnten sie herausfinden oder waren es
mitbekommen wie wichtig solche politiker
besucher in der ukraine werden
wahrgenommen überhaupt es wird sehr viel
wahrgenommen was in deutschland passiert
und was für briefe geschrieben werden
zumindest für die interessierten leute
mit denen ich mich darüber unterhalten
habe die wussten teilweise vor mir
bescheid da gab es wieder einen brief
von intellektuellen in deutschland nicht
sagt aber randständige personen und dann
guckte ich nee das war jetzt schon
wieder neuer briefen die sind gar nicht
so anständig und das wird registriert
weil deutschland wird einfach als
wichtigstes land in europa wahrgenommen
und ja man empfindet das als nicht wird
es nicht zu sehr auf fristen da aber
schon als eine art von doppelten verrat
erst eben diese man muss ja sagen
verfehlte wirtschafts und
rüstungspolitik deutschlands
wobei die ukraine relativ hingehängt hat
und jetzt einfach sich sehr zurück zu
halten bei der lieferung von von
rüstungsgütern das heißt aber da auch in
diesem zusammenhang sind dann bilder
sowie annalena baerbock die dann bei
saarland geht's dann auch eben wichtig
ja das ist wichtig aber es nutzt sich
natürlich auch ab ich glaube wenn
annalena baerbock nochmals schritt
weiter geht jetzt ja und dann das
besonders sympathisch gestaltet oder
wenn sie ihn in den herrn kohl immer
dann in den arm nimmt dann ist das gut
und wichtig ich glaube dass scholz jetzt
kommt dann sagen alle sehr gut jetzt
wurde auch getrieben so
nicht kommen hat aber am montag
präsidenten empfangen und beide sind
dann zum brandenburger tor gegangen das
dann in den farben der ukrainischen
flagge angestrahlt war vielleicht das
bild können wir auch eben zeigen das war
dann dieses bild die beiden wichtigsten
männer europas wahrscheinlich vor dem
brandenburger tor in diesen farben
eigentlich hätten sie sich an den händen
fassen müssen sie mit ruhe und kohlen
aber ich finde ja dass in diesem ganzen
krieg den politiker bilder nicht
entscheidend sind also viel wichtiger
sind ja die bilder aus dem
kriegsgeschehen selbst nicht also ich
glaube die ikonographie dieses krieges
sind doch tatsächlich die bilder aus
mario pohl von dieser völlig zerstörten
stadt es sind bilder aus butter was sie
eine eindrückliche vorhin geschildert
haben wir wo wir dann tote sehen auch
sehr nahe sehen also ich habe den
eindruck dass es auch für viele leute
vielleicht zu viel isst was man da zeigt
dass andere stimmen sagen wie das ist
wichtig im krieg zu zeigen was dort
geschieht und interessant ist ja dann
auf der anderen seite dass wir
eigentlich keine vergleichbare
ikonographie aus russland haben nicht es
gibt keine bilder von den friedhöfen wo
soldaten beigesetzt dafür ihre eigenen
müttern die ihre von weinen genau für
trauernden müttern die die trauern oder
auch alltagsbilder also ich hatte jetzt
vor unserer sendung auch noch mal
gesprochen mit ich werde nach für
reporter ohne grenzen immer dieses
fotobuch presse also fotos für die
pressefreiheit das kommt immer zum tag
der pressefreiheit raus und ritter mai
und habe mit meiner kollegin gesprochen
die für die fotoseite zuständig ist
barbara stauss und die sagte dass auch
so interessant wir haben eigentlich gar
kein bild von russland
und dann habe ich eine russische
freundin heute gefragt gesagt was
würdest du denn sagen was ist denn das
bild im moment hat es ja auch sehr lange
nachgedacht und sagte ja weißt du was
mir einfällt ist das ist im moment so
grau ist wie noch nie also ganz anders
als hier in berlin ist es gar nicht grün
im moment und ich fand es dann gedacht
okay das wäre es vielleicht so ein bild
aber da ist glaube ich eine riesige
lücke also jenseits von putin und dieser
parade haben wir da eigentlich wenig
wurde eine gewollte luca werner klar
dass auch teil natürlich dieser
medienzensur nicht mehr kirchner
ja ich würde noch mal ganz gern auf das
bild zurückkommen wollen am
brandenburger tor vielleicht wenn sie
dann aber ganz kurz zeigen können weil
ich find die körpersprache dann total
interessant also in dieser botschaft die
dort raus kommen denn wir sehen ja dass
tatsächlich möglichst eine asymmetrie
gibt dafür einen seite wirklich makro
der dort steht der natürlich also etwas
größer ist das heißt er wirkt erst mal
größer ist das eine aber macondo grit
scholz während scholz eben nicht balkon
berührt und das erste dieser sogenannte
kumpel griff also das heißt es hat ja
auch was fürsorglich ist aber
gleichzeitig eben auch sowas zupackt ist
und die botschaft dahinter ist ziemlich
deutlich dort wo eben deutschland das er
ist ja gerade gesagt worden als
europäisches land sehr sehr wichtiges
markiert makro damit auch symbolisch
diesen führungsanspruch im sinne von ich
bin derjenige der der volksfestzeit
bezahle ich bin auch der inhalt der in
der situation die kontrolle behält und
gleichzeitig natürlich wollen beide
diese botschaft der geschlossenheit sind
das heißt dieses bild hat natürlich auch
einen kontext der da lautet makro will
sich als europäer inszenieren und das
natürlich auch absolut relevant vor den
entsprechenden wahlen die ja auch in
frankreich liegen insgesamt es schwierig
brandenburger tor in 1 farben des
regenbogens anzustrahlen wir haben es
jetzt wirklich in allen landesflagge
haben wir schon gesehen wenn
terroranschläge waren jetzt die ukraine
das ist einfach eine verlegenheits geste
finde ich dann haben sie sich überlegt
was können wir machen also zusammen da
hingegangen dann gucken sie hatten sich
daraufhin leicht unter sichtlich wurde
von hinten der eine legt die hand auf
ich finde es aber nicht ja ich werde mir
das gar nicht so furchtbar abgeschmackt
es gibt auch andere bilder das war die
frage auf der bildauswahl also wir als
journalistinnen und journalisten
legitimerweise wählen sie ein bild aus
von vielen und es gibt auch genau von
diesem moment andere bilder wo es finde
ich weniger starke asymmetrie
beschrieben hat gibt wo ist eigentlich
ein gemeinsames auch im arm liegen gibt
es so ein stück weit also das ist dann
immer die frage welches bild man auch
zeigt hier sieht's bin ich auch ein
bisschen aus als würde man frau scholz
dazu packen
und das ist dann natürlich medial von
der vom negativ interessant weil es so
ein bisschen dieses narrativ verstärkt
scholz ist so ein bisschen der
zurückhaltende der zauderer und micron
ist der der in europa nach vorne prescht
dass so eine
führungsrolle für sich beansprucht also
hier werden dann im grunde so ein
bisschen
eingeschlagenen aktive und stereotype
verstetigt obwohl man auch ein anderes
bild hätte wählen können also dass
unterschiedliche meinung der darüber
frau weil es eben angefangen wir haben
kein bild über über russland glauben sie
das ist eben haben sie auch noch einmal
gesagt ist das gewollt so gäbe es denn
die möglichkeit das zu ändern gibt es ja
jetzt im moment nicht gewusst ich sagte
das ist teil der medienzensur also wir
eben einfach merken da wird sehr
gesteuert irgendwie auch
propagandistisch welche bilder denn da
nach außen dringen sollen oder welche
bilder eben auch vor allem im eigenen
land zu sehen sind das hätte natürlich
eine enorme sprengkraft so gerade die
weinende mütter oder die friedhöfe oder
die särge die zurückkommen die bilder
gibt es natürlich ganz bewusst nicht nur
stattdessen gibt es eben sehr viele
propagandistische bilder gefälschte
bilder oder bilder da die ihm in einer
anderen zusammenhang gestellt werden und
eben dadurch eben auch
instrument eben sind der machtausübung
und des versuchs eine ganze bevölkerung
in die irre zu führen
über das was tatsächlich in der ukraine
geschieht und welche brutalität dieser
russische angriffskrieg in wahrheit hat
also wichtig ist eben ist dass reporter
eben ihre arbeit tun können vor ort das
merken wir auch in der ukraine in mario
pohl gibt es einen eindringlichen
bericht von den letzten reportern die
dann abgezogen sind von amerikanischen
grünen namen geschrieben weil ich mich
nicht so gut bin mit klinischen namen
mister slavko von jewgeni mal etwa von
der epi waren da die sind ganz bewusst
hingefahren ist krieg ausbruch ausbrach
weil sie wussten dass wird einer der
hauptpunkte werden für für jost armee
und sind einfach reingegangen eine stadt
eigentlich eingekesselt werden musste
und haben dann einen job da gemacht der
fast seinesgleichen sucht glaube ich in
diesem krieg wo viele leute guten job
gemacht haben
wirklich unter stetigem einsatz ihres
lebens
fantastische bilder gemacht und berichte
abgesetzt unter anderem von dieser
bombardierten geburtsklinik ich erinnere
mich an das bild eines 12 eines mannes
der
gleichen lage und der vater sich über
ihn über ihn beugt sich sein sohn und so
weiter und so fort und als ja dann
glaube ich wirklich schon nach ihm
gesucht wurde da sind sie dann raus
geschleust wurden und die da treffe ich
da die sind weiterhin ich habe es euch
sagen umfeld in aktiv in der politik am
donnerstag das weiter und suchen dass
das war für mich eine der wirklich
herausragenden leistung und wir waren
schon einmal ganz kurz alte schriften
das thema auch bilder von toten zeigt
man tote es gab die seine bildwelt die
frühe anfang märz im krieg von lenz ja
darüber von der new york times die da
war als als wirklich die brücke oder
zumindest das vorfeld der brücke
bombardiert worden die leute flüchteten
aus eppingen und den anderen vororten
und da sind ja dann seine mutter mit
ihren zwei kindern glaub ich gestorben
und ein fluchthelfer wie sich dann
herausstellte
und dann auch unter lebensgefahr ist das
foto entstanden ich habe heute noch mal
im podcast gehört wo sie das alles
erklärt und die new york times hat das
auf der titelseite gebracht und nicht
verpixelt und sie hatten eigentlich
haben sie gesagt die regel wir zeigen
keine gesichter von toten das haben sie
aber sowas von gebrochen die regel und
dann zwei tage später meldete sich der
vater der hinterbliebene dieser familie
und sagte ich bin wahnsinnig dankbar
dass das passiert ist und so und das
nicht nur was gibt's das fotografische
angeht sondern auch das endliche haben
es mir immer wieder begegne ich leute
sind wirklich dankbar dass wir da sind
ich habe langes gespräch gehabt mit
einer aus ersatzteil evakuierten mutter
mit ihren zwei kindern deren mann immer
noch da ist die sagte die 20 dankbar
dass wir mit ihr reden hat sich die zeit
genommen und nacheinander mit
verschiedenen journalisten sofern das
ist gut
das einfach kollegen wie herr schröder
und fotografen die dort unten sind
machen eine wahnsinnig wichtige arbeit
nicht das ist einfach auch zeit
historisch sind dass irgendwann die
dokumente auf die über dann wird
geschichte geschrieben und es sind auch
dokumente die wichtig sind um die
gräueltaten aufzuwachsen und anklage zu
erinnern dann hier her dass er
der kirchentag jahre dann hätte ich ja
bitte
ja also die frage ist ja genau warum ist
diese regel gebrochen worden denn
schröder sie haben's ja gesagt die gibt
es an sich aus gutem grund wir haben die
schwierigkeit ist doch die dass dieses
ganze geschehen relativ sinnlos ist und
dass natürlich auch dieser tod ziemlich
sinnlos ist gerade in diesem krieg und
in dem moment wo man aber tatsächlich
diese personen zeigt ja ich meine die
frage natürlich des konsenses stellt
sich aber um und die personen zeigt und
die person wird ja erst zur person durch
das gesicht ist es natürlich dann auch
ein mahnmal ja wirklich ein
personifiziertes mahnmal gegen den krieg
und das wir um schaffte überhaupt
erstmal sinn plus es gibt ja auch so
diese tendenz dass man sagt wir hatten
so diese menschen die interessieren uns
nicht gerade in diesem russischen
relativ nah sie einzelnen interessieren
uns nicht und hier wird aber einzelnen
leuten zu gehört das wird deren
geschichte angehört und es wird eben
tatsächlich dem leitbild gegeben das
heißt damit wird eben auch eine sinn
stiftung vermittelt und genau das ist
etwas was genau dazu führt dass es in
dem fall wahrscheinlich wirklich richtig
ist genau das zu machen aber diese frage
der bilder in russland nur ganz kurz
russland hat sich das ja anders
vorgestellt die haben sich vorgestellt
dass die bilder zeigen wie sie in kiew
dann wirklich triumphierend durchgehend
das heißt es sind auch deshalb keine
bilder weil sie nicht die bilder haben
die sie haben wollten und weil die
tatsächlichen bilder eben nicht dazu
dienen legitimation für das russische
vorgehen zu schaffen er hält ihr müsste
man dann konsequenterweise nicht viel
mehr bilder von diesen gräueltaten
unverfälscht ganz klar zeigen
das ist eine schwierige frage es gibt
wahrscheinlich auch irgendwann einen
menschlichen reflex da ein stück weit
ich will nicht sagen abzuschalten aber
auch zum zumindest ein stück weit
abzustumpfen ich glaube dass man diese
bilder zeigen muss man muss und sollte
sie aber wahrscheinlich dosieren und wir
erleben übrigens auch das war der
ausgang unserer diskussion in der
kommunikation von selensky ganz bewusst
diese verwendung der bilder also es gibt
ja neben der zielgruppe ukrainische
bevölkerung und russische bevölkerung
auch die zielgruppe globale
öffentlichkeit präsident begann stark
und da sind nicht nur die reden in
nationalen parlamenten und auf seine
übersetzten täglichen videobotschaften
ein zentrales element sondern auch immer
wieder die bildsprache
er postet regelmäßig bilder von kindern
die vor trümmern stehen auch von leichen
und er hat auch solche bilder schon
gezeigt damals im us-kongress bei seiner
ansprache wir haben auch sehr verstört
also lenski nutzt das weil er weiß das
ist eine emotionale moralische ebene mit
der er druck ausüben kann in den
öffentlichkeiten in den ländern von der
von denen er mehr unterstützung
einfordert und würden sie das recht
denken sie dass sich das ab nutzen kann
dann so wie er es einsetzt
das ist ein bisschen meine befürchtung
und ich glaube aber es kommt auf die
dosierung an das ist das was ich eben
meine und es ist ja nicht so dass er das
jeden tag tut sondern er tut das so nach
meiner beobachtung
einmal in der woche dass er da eine
reihe von bildern zeigt das sind auch
nicht immer leicht das sind mal kinder
die vor trümmerhaufen stehen er
verwendet auch tiere manchmal das ist
interessant katzen die durch die trümmer
laufen es gab eine runde ein und von der
armee der ausgezeichnet wurde für seine
leistung als es gibt all diese emotionen
maschine ebenen
und die visualisierte ok vielen dank
herr helia vielen dank herr kirchner
prozent wir sind am ende der sendung
leider sind am ende unserer sendezeit
deshalb muss ich hier schluss machen
vielen dank herr schröder viel erfolg
weiter oder alles gute vor allen dingen
für das berichten dort erfolg ist das
falsche wort entschuldigung alles gute
einfach da für morgen hat gibt sich eine
führungsrunde dann fragen wir bündnisse
gegen putin wie verändert der krieg nato
und die eu schön wenn sie dann auch
wieder dabei sind jetzt folgt für nichts
der tag mit anja charlie bis dahin
tschüss